A bug triage is the process by which the severity of different bugs is determined,
and we start to disambiguate between different bugs
in order to basically try to get a handle on which bugs we can report in parallel.
The deal is that any inputs that trigger separate bugs can be reported in parallel,
but if we report all of the bug-triggering inputs that we found,
what we're going to do is be causing a lot of duplicate bug reports.
One of the golden rules of reporting bugs--and I'll go over this a little bit later in more detail--
is that you don't report duplicate bugs.
This wears on developers incredibly much,
and they'll soon get tired of you and start ignoring you.
I say this from experience. I've reported quite a few duplicate bugs myself.
It's not that fun. People don't like it.
The question now is what does bug triage mean.
How do we start getting a handle on which bug-triggering inputs
map to different bugs and which ones map to the same bugs.
Basically, there is no silver bullet here.
What we have is we're going to see there is a number of different weapons
we can use to disambiguate bugs.
In an easy-as-possible case the bugs in the system are causing assertion violation messages.
One thing we can do is disambiguate based on assertion violations.
What I basically mean here is that you do what I gave a demonstration of doing
a little bit earlier, which is you just look at the text of the assertion violation messages,
and you go ahead and make the assumption that distinct assertion violation messages
are caused by distinct bugs in the software under test, and that doesn't need to be true.
Not too long ago I reported something like six bugs in the LLVM compiler
that had completely distinct symptoms--
that is to say, completely distinct assertion violation messages--
but they were all traced back to a single error in the source code.
Of course that kind of thing can happen,
and that's especially common if the underlying bug in the software under test
is some sort of a memory safety violation.
That is to say, we have a C or C++ program
that starts corrupting it's own internal memory.
In that case, a single bug can map to any number of symptoms.
One possibility is that we have a single root cause
that is a defect in the software under test.
That can map multiple outputs that looks different.
This is one possibility, and this happens, although maybe not that often.
Another possibility is that we could have multiple defects that all cause the same symptom.
This is actually really common.
For example, in a big C or C++ program like a web browser
it's very common for multiple memory safety defects--
that is to say, multiple bugs that include things like buffer overruns
and null pointer references--
to all have the same symptom, which is segmentation fault.
That happens really commonly.
In contrast with these slightly pathological cases,
what we hope happens--and this is also relatively common--
is that a single defect maps to a single symptom.
By reporting a test case leading to that symptom, we can get that defect fixed.
So, in this case we have many defects,
all mapping to their own symptoms in the output space,
we can report these in parallel, and that's really nice.
Like I was saying, with large, complicated software that's evolving rapidly,
reporting bugs in parallel may be our only option,
if we want to actually get the number of defects in the software under control.